democrats are doing terribly in the
generic midterm ballot they're
underwater on almost every single issue
so you know what that means that's right
kovitt is making a comeback
many americans are under vaccinated
meaning they are not up to date on their
coven 19 vaccines
not all people over the age of 50 have
received their first booster dose of
those who've received their first
booster dose only 28 of those over 50
have received a second booster dose and
of those over the age of 65 only 34
percent have received their second
booster dose so my message right now is
very simple it's essential that these
americans as dr
jah said get their second booster shot
right away
it is essential says the director of the
cdc
that you all get your fourth shot
of the totally safe and effective
vaccine that was supposed to stop you
from catching and transmitting kovid the
first time and never throughout all of
the various boosters ever actually did
either of those things now some
intelligent people might be thinking
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
thrice
quadrice
shame on me but for anyone who might be
tempted to have an independent thought
here
question these genius experts dr fauci
is here with an important message
shut up
everybody wants to put
this
pandemic behind us
and feel and hope that it doesn't exist
it does
don't hope
stop hoping
he is actually telling you to stop
hoping
at this point because he
and walensky and most of all biden
realize that people are finally seeing
through their nonsense
and pushing back against their power
grab
but as a certain mr
nostradamus may have predicted
hate to say i told you so but as i may
have predicted on this very show last
week
covet is the only issue on which biden
and the democrats are even slightly
above water and it's also the key issue
that allows them to mess around with all
of the election rules so you can bet
your bottom dollar that this is going to
be the issue that they hammer harder and
harder as we approach what they fear
will be a wipeout in the november
elections i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music who says when
asked for comment on the first lady's
insensitive taco blunder joe biden
replied come on man
that is
actually my favorite comment i've ever
read
on the show it's a really great dad joke
it's a great padre joke and i'm
absolutely going to steal it biden is
trying anything it is spaghetti at the
wall if kovid's the only thing that even
slightly works for him he's going to go
with kovid
the numbers are absolutely devastating
for this guy i'm not talking about among
republicans obviously i'm not talking
about among independents or moderates
even
among democrats according to a new poll
from the new york times in siena college
just 26 of democrats want joe biden to
be the nominee in 2024.
one in four democrats wants the
incumbent democrat president to be the
nominee in 2024 absolutely
devastating a full 64 percent of
democrat voters actively want someone
else to run in the 2024 presidential
campaign
and then 10 percent i guess just have no
idea what they're talking about
scott adams the dilbert guy had a really
great point on this the other day you'll
notice the way we're talking about joe
biden and and the way we're talking
about hunter biden in particular
is with a great deal of sympathy we're
saying ah man hunter biden what a
degenerate he is yeah he's a criminal
he's done terrible things he should be
held accountable but ah the poor guy
i'll poor joe biden he's falling off a
bicycle oh my gosh this is so he can't
say his own words he can't read the
teleprompter he doesn't know where he is
no one wants to talk to him at the white
house gatherings they have someone in an
easter bunny suit walking around to try
to guide him places so he doesn't wander
off this is sad i feel sad for joe biden
this is what
scott adams calls the dole turn
he's referring to the 96 presidential
campaign bill clinton versus the
republican bob dole and at a certain
point in the campaign clinton started
talking about how he respected bob
dole's military service and he started
saying sort of nice things about dole
and
what scott believes is that's the moment
when clinton
stopped fearing dole
when clinton thought dole is done
there's no way he's going to win so now
i can say nice things about him and
that's the way people are talking about
joe biden
no matter what happens in 2024 i'm not
saying the republican is definitely
going to win that presidential campaign
but at the moment it just seems so
unlikely that biden even gets the
nomination that people are talking about
him now and this oh poor sad joe oh man
this old demented poor sad joe that's
really bad news news for joe biden even
though his opponents are saying nice
things about him they're saying nice
things about him because they don't fear
him at all anymore now compare
and contrast what the way the democrats
are talking about biden with the way
republicans are talking about trump
the way republicans are talking about
trump they want him to run again and
they expect him to run again and many
expect him to win according to a morning
consult politico polls so this is
another left-wing poll
two-thirds of republicans want trump to
run again
they took this poll last october and
they asked republicans how many of you
want trump to run again the number was
67 percent fully two-thirds
and they've been hammering this guy and
they've had the january 6th committee
and you've seen other candidates
position themselves in a strong way
especially ron desantis in florida and
even with all of that even with all of
that do you know what the number is
today
it was 67 in october today 66
of republicans want trump to run again
even after this deluge of negative press
booting trump out of the public square
off of social media even with all of
that he's lost one percentage point
this guy if if donald trump runs for the
nomination
right now he wins it it's not even close
it's not even remotely no matter ron
desantis is amazing he's the greatest
governor in florida maybe the greatest
governor in america of my lifetime
doesn't matter
very very it's gonna be very very hard
to close that gap
and it's funny the way that the way that
this was all presented to us a year ago
two years ago you have joe biden this
unifier the adult in the room the man
who's going to bring us together return
to normalcy and here's trump a terrible
awful insurrectionist who's not even a
true republican not even a true
conservative and what do you have now
you got the democrats throwing biden
overboard and you've got the republicans
essentially rallying around trump trump
is is even getting support from unlikely
places this is my favorite
my favorite defense of trump that we've
seen so far you know the january 6th
committee is still rolling along and
they're so close adam schiff liz cheney
they're so close they've got they're
just one more week and they're gonna
prove that donald trump is
secretly hitler or something donald
trump secretly tried to overthrow the
government
and it's they're just not proving it
they've never proven this case they had
an impeachment trial didn't do anything
they had two impeachment trials didn't
do anything it's not real john bolton
who is donald trump's national security
adviser then he kind of turned against
trump he wrote a book that was highly
critical of trump he's going on a lot of
tv shows critical of trump he's broadly
supportive of people like liz cheney a
lot of people who so
john bolton has a lot of bonafides these
days with the libs he goes on cnn he
goes on msnbc so he's on cnn and jake
tapper says this was an insurrection
donald trump led an insurrection and
john bolton says actually jake
not so much
it's not an attack on our democracy it's
donald trump looking out for donald
trump it's a once in a lifetime
occurrence i don't know that i agree
with you to be to be uh fair with all
due respect uh one doesn't have to be
brilliant to attempt a coup uh i
disagree with that as somebody who has
helped plan coup d'etat
not here but you know other places
it takes a lot of work and that's not
what he did it was just stumbling around
from one idea to another ultimately he
did unleash the rioters at the capitol
as to that there's no doubt but not
overthrow the constitution to buy more
time to throw the matter back to the
states to try and redo the issue and if
you don't believe that you're gonna
overreact and i think that's a real risk
for the committee
i absolutely love it it's marvelous i
know john bolton is not the most popular
guy in conservative circles these days
how do you not love that
no actually john we had you on this show
to criticize trump and i'm pretty sure
this listen this was a coup d'etat uh
jake
you have no idea what you're talking
about it's hard for me i can't even get
the john bolton ethos because i don't
have that giant walrus mustache but he's
just standing there looking tough as now
he goes jake you don't know what you're
talking about as somebody who has
planned plenty of coup d'etat around the
world
i know what i'm talking about listen
listen jake this is not a coup d'etat
kudeta was a friend of mine i knew
kudeta and january 6th was no
coup d'etat and he's right
he's right and uh
if janua january 6 had been a coup
d'etat
we would have a new government right now
because
the
insurrectionists so-called
they made it into the heart of the
senate into the heart of the house of
representatives they could have declared
a new government but what happened
what happened the horn hat guy walked in
to the chambers
as being escorted by police and then he
stood up and he kind of danced around a
little bit and the various people showed
up and they kind of made a mess of nancy
pelosi's office and then they went home
and they had a coors light in the
capital rotunda and then they left there
there was no plan to overthrow the
government there was no plan to rip up
the constitution declare a new
government
it was
rowdy it was a riot sure
it was not a coup d'etat you heard it
from the horse's
mouth
now
speaking of really important true things
you've got to go check out ramp right
now go to ramp.com
knowles do you want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses
payments accounting if so ramp could be
a complete game changer ramp is a
corporate card and financial software
suite designed to help you save time and
put money back in your pocket ramp gives
finance teams unprecedented control and
insight into company spend with ramp you
are able to create budgets issue cards
to every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense
reporting so you can stop wasting time
at the end of every month ramps
accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to i absolutely love this software the
time you will save each month on
employee expenses will allow you to
close your books in days not weeks ramp
saves you money businesses that use ramp
save an average of 3.3 percent the first
year that's a lot of money ramp is easy
to use
get started issue virtual and physical
cards start making payments in less than
15 minutes whether you've got five
employees or five thousand and now get
250 dollars when you join ramp go to
ramp.com knowles ramp dot com slash can
a w l e s cars issued by celtic bank
members fdic
crazy things going on in the capital i'm
not talking about january 6th i'm
talking about the most bizarre hearing
that i have ever seen take place in the
united states senate and i had to check
myself on this i have not spent a lot of
time around the u.s senate but i spoke
last night to senator ted cruz and i
said hey man you were in that hearing
today
that was pretty nuts right and he said
michael in my decade in the senate i
have never seen anything crazier the
hearing was about abortion there was one
person in particular who is testifying
berkeley law professor chiara bridges
who
had
had the entire testimony descend into a
debate over whether or not men can get
pregnant this this occurred in
particular during an exchange with
senator josh hawley this exchange is a
little bit long trust me it's worth it
you've referred to people with a
capacity for pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy um there are
also trans men who are capable of
pregnancy as well as non-binary people
who are capable of pregnancy so this
isn't really a women's rights issue it's
uh we can recognize that this impacts
women while also recognizing that it
impacts other groups those things are
not mutually exclusive senator hawley so
your view is is that the core of this
this right then is about what
so um i want to recognize that your line
of questioning um is transphobic
and it opens up trans people to violence
by not recognizing that wow you're
saying that i'm opening up people to
violence by asking whether or not women
are the folks who can have pregnancies
so i'm one i want to note that one out
of five transgender
persons have attempted suicide so i
think it's important because of my line
of questioning so we can't talk about it
because denying that trans people exist
and pretending not to know that they
exist i'm denying that trans people
exist by asking are you if you're are
you about women are you having
pregnancies do you believe that the uh
men can get pregnant
no i don't think so so you're denying
that trans people like this and that
leads to violence is this how you run
your classroom are students allowed to
question you or are they also treated
like this or are you interested
opening up people to violence we have a
good time in my class you should join
you might learn a lot wow i would learn
a lot i've learned a lot i know it's
exciting absolutely extraordinary what
an extraordinary magnificent exchange uh
senator hawley deserves an award for
patience
you can tell you look at that woman's
eyes and the crazy is there because
you're you're denying the trans people
exist he goes what what how did i do
that do you think men can get pregnant
uh no well and
you're denying that they exist and she
keeps using this phrase she uses this
phrase people who can get pregnant
people who are capable of pregnancy
all of these euphemisms because she
doesn't want to say the word woman
and she believes the word woman i guess
is transphobic the real irony here is in
the harvard law review this woman kiara
bridges has an article from just just a
couple of years ago this is january 2020
in which she uses the word woman
45 times and the word women 349 times
while talking about abortion she's
speaking she's specifically an expert on
abortion and in just two years
she has completely changed her her mode
of speaking her
mode of thinking about human nature and
now the word woman with regard to
pregnancy and abortion is considered
transphobic so i endorse this woman for
the democrat nominee for president i
think that kiara bridges the more that
we play of kiara bridges on tv on the
internet we put her out on the campaign
trail i think that republicans are going
to win all 57 states if if we put this
woman out there as the face of the
democrat party the democrats seem fine
with this they they call this berkeley
law professor to come testify they agree
with a lot of her premises and to her
credit by the way
i haven't seen a lot of conservatives
defending this point but it we really
should to be fair
when she says that conservatives believe
that trans people don't exist
she's right she's correct conservatives
do not believe that trans people exist
they don't they don't exist that's not
it's
transgender is not a category of being
that is real
you can't be that some people might say
well listen i believe that trans people
exist i believe that people think that
they're the opposite sex they're not
really the opposite sex but i think they
think that right so you're saying people
with
gender identity disorder exist you're
saying people with gender dysphoria
exist but transgender people do not
exist they can't exist because to be
transgender is to accept or to even
accept the category of transgenderism is
to accept the premise that a man really
can be a woman
that's why there's a different term for
transgenderism and gender identity
disorder this is why the people who are
men who think that they're women
identify themselves as transgender they
don't identify themselves as people with
gender identity disorder
sort of like saying
you know someone a skinny person who
thinks that he is a fat person is
anorexic
yes he he is
he is anorexic he is not
a
secretly fat person
he is not a
invisibly fat person
in this in this analogy here anorexia
and gender identity disorder and gender
dysphoria these are all medical
conditions that ought to be treated and
corrected
transgenderism male to female or female
to male or a transitioned person would
be the
analogous to a
really skinny very fat person it's just
it's a
it's a logical impossibility it's not a
real category and conservatives don't
want to say this because one will be
de-platformed if you tweet that out if
you say transgender people do not exist
i think that is a direct violation of
twitter's rules and so you could be
taken off the platform for that
so we're not allowed to say that and we
also feel kind of icky
we've accepted the left's premise that
it's somehow bigoted to say that
transgender people do not exist no
people exist confused people exist
sexually
eccentric people exist but transgender
people do not exist they cannot exist
because that is not an actual
ontological category
not to put too fine a point on it until
recently not even the libs thought that
transgender people exist you look no
further than the woman who created the
tv show friends friends is the
absolutely
liberal sitcom par excellence from the
1990s
these people living in new york living
kind of liberal
decadent lives it
pushes a broadly liberal not exclusively
but broadly liberal message and one of
the jokes in the show is that chandler's
father is a transvestite
that was one of the one of the jokes in
the show and now the co-creator marta
kaufman has had to apologize for this
she says we kept referring to chandler's
father
to helena the character as chandler's
father
even though chandler's father was trans
and she suggested that they ought to
have referred to chandler's father once
he had transitioned as chandler's mother
she says pronouns were not yet something
that i understood so we didn't refer to
that character as she that was a mistake
so the whole reason that they had this
character of chandler's father who who
was a transvestite
is because it's funny because men aren't
supposed to do that it was funny and so
the the juxtaposition the incongruity
there is funny and it's supposed to make
you laugh on the situational comedy
but now
we're living in a world of absurdity
we're living in clown world and so the
things that were funny even to the
liberals
20 years ago are now very somber and
serious
and now now this woman marta kaufman the
things she's saying on her apology tour
are much funnier than anything that ever
aired on friends the idea that
when a father
pretends to be a woman that he all of a
sudden becomes your mother
that is that is much crazier even than
saying that a man can become a woman
chandler's father unfriends i can't
believe we're spending this much time on
chandler's father in this stupid tv show
but chandler's father
even if he puts on a dress even if he
calls himself helena even if everyone
accepts that he is now actually a woman
still would not be chandler's mother
chandler's father did not bear chandler
in his womb
chandler's
father did not give birth to chandler
chandler's father even if he forces
everybody to accept the absurd notion
that he is now a woman chandler's father
cannot possibly ever have been or be now
chandler's mother a mother is an actual
role that that involves having done
something to another person to be a
mother is to
define yourself in a relationship to
another person namely your child
and if you do not have the relationship
of mother and child then you can't
be that mother
this is rad this is the logical
illogical conclusion of radical
individualism but it reminds us this is
i'm sure marta kaufman did not sign up
for this when she went on her apology
tour about the transvestite jokes but it
actually shows you why the leftist
and
hyper individualist even you sometimes
see it on the right why these views of
humanity are ultimately insufficient
the the view that we're just we're just
living for us just me me all hyper
individualism on the left they talk
about it socially and the right they
tend to talk more economically but the
idea that we are just individuals born
as free-floating atoms that's ridiculous
the way that we view our identities in
society are relational because man is a
social creature the political animal we
define our roles in life in relation to
one another if you're a wife that means
that you have a husband you cannot be a
wife if you don't have a husband if
you're a mother you have to have a child
you cannot be a mother without having a
child
if you're a child a son or a daughter
means you have to have a mother or a
father we are relational beings that's
why you have to have some grasp on
reality because if we're all just living
in our own deluded fantasy lands we we
sever the connection that we have to one
another we can no longer even
communicate we can't even use the word
woman
now while
the left's celebration of pride has
ended
what is a woman
is still
one of the most popular movies at home
on rotten tomatoes it's got a 97
audience score from well over 5000
ratings it is still getting talked about
even if mainstream reviewers will not
touch it a daily wire is known for
creating fearless documentaries such as
what is a woman that's just the tip of
the iceberg of
delicious delightful
treats that you will get when you
subscribe to daily wire plus which is
everything you love about the daily wire
and so much more as a member you get
exclusive access to new shows and
content from jordan peterson plus the
entire prageru library plus original
movies and documentaries plus animated
and live action kids content coming soon
we are building the future that you want
to see come join us head over to
dailywireplus.com
become a member that's dailywireplus.com
today use code knowles for 25 off also
make sure to check out craning company
dailywire's new sports show yours truly
will be there on all access tomorrow
morning so tune in to see if my
nostradamus powers of prophecy and
prediction will help me with my sports
knowledge we'll be right back with a lot
more
i discovered a contradiction on dead
naming
i did
i i've just on behalf of the transgender
community i discovered a a great
travesty that has gone on in hollywood
of all places
ellen page she who must not be named she
who if you name her on twitter you will
be kicked off of twitter and booted out
of the public square ellen page the
actress who now says she's a man and
goes by elliot page
is being dead named dead named that's
when you call someone by their real name
not their new crazy fake name she is
being dead named
by hollywood by the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences by the oscars
if you go on the oscars website
you will notice that they still list
ellen page
under their nominees because she was
nominated for that movie juno
and we all laugh because yes of course
she even if you think that she's a man
now which she isn't she obviously was a
woman in juno it's a movie it's a movie
about a woman getting an abortion though
i guess you could talk to that berkeley
professor and she'd say that men can get
abortions too we all look at that we say
ellen didn't call herself elliot in
those days ellen called herself ellen
and knew that she was a woman she's
called herself ellen for 33 for 35 years
on earth so of course but the new rule
on wikipedia on social media on twitter
on on facebook on youtube all these
places is
if someone now identifies with a new
name and new pronouns you have to refer
to that person by those names
by that name and by those pronouns
when referring to their entire life and
here
we we see an example of of a
contradiction
the academy we're now halfway into july
the academy still has its pride flag up
on its social media profiles so it says
where are the lgbt as lgbt as they come
well they are dead naming
ellen page
are they going to be kicked off of
twitter are they going to be booted out
of the public square are they probably
not they're probably not going to face
any consequences at all but it is rank
hypocrisy
the academy gets to dead name ellen page
jordan peterson does not what's that
about well what that's about is there's
two sets of rules speaking of popular
films
i i hope that you have not
watched too much of hunter biden's
hunter biden his laptop was
exposed and his cell phone was exposed
and the guy
the guy filmed himself committing all
sorts of
disgusting acts i think i'm not sure
that the guy has ever committed a crime
that he did not film
lots and lots of hookers lots and lots
of drugs lots and lots of creepy stuff
it's all out there with video evidence
of the guy committing all sorts of
crimes we have documentary evidence of
him committing what are probably more
serious financial crimes evidence of
lots of
lots of financial corruption
and now they're saying
it is being reported that hunter biden
could face charges
not for the financial stuff not even for
the drug stuff just for the hookers but
according to experts
in the mainstream media
joe biden's son hunter could face
federal charges related to prostitution
while he's under investigation for other
stuff he could face charges
according to the experts but according
to people who know how the political
system actually works he won't
he won't he's not gonna he's not gonna
face
any actual consequences do you do you
really believe that hunter biden is ever
going to be wearing an orange jumpsuit
no you don't
but he should yeah sure
and it's unjust uh-huh
but do you believe right now that hunter
biden is ever going to face actual
consequences
for his brazen
criminality
no and why won't he because we know that
there are two tracks in the justice
system just as there are two tracks for
ordinary people on the street
just as there are two tracks four blm
goes out and burns down buildings and
kills people and robs stores and they
get a slap on the wrist and usually get
their charges dismissed meanwhile the
horn hat guy goes in and dances around
the capitol they throw him in solitary
throw away the key
two different tracks for political
dissent
and protest uh so too there are
different drafts for people who are
connected hunter biden is joe biden's
son he just won't face
consequences now speaking of crime and
punishment this is really important
because when
when
crime begins to spread it has effects
all throughout society there are
actually three kinds of criminality that
we're talking about here we're talking
about crime like regular thug on the
street goes and robs a liquor store then
we're talking about lawlessness in the
enforcement agencies the fbi and other
law enforcement agencies when they don't
enforce the law and they let criminals
off the hook that's another kind of
lawlessness and then there's the third
kind that you see typified by hunter
biden
and other members of the biden family
where people who are connected to the
government the people who are supposed
to be
setting the better example who are
either directly or indirectly involved
in law enforcement through family ties
when they are the ones committing the
crimes
those are three different types of
lawlessness the latter is the most
scandalous
and
when one spreads they all kind of spread
you don't when when the law enforcement
agencies stop enforcing the law what
happens you get more crime when the
people at the top who were supposed to
be in charge in setting the example when
they commit crimes themselves that sends
a message to the rest of the law
enforcement agencies that now we're not
going to take these things so seriously
no one really believes biden's fbi and
biden's doj are going to go after hunter
biden no one really believes that and
they're gonna by the way when when the
kamala harris is out raising money to
bail out the blm rioters
that's a message to the blm riders and
to antifa and just regular street thugs
that they're not going to get in trouble
as long as they check a few different
boxes they're going to be just fine and
so the lawlessness spreads
you see it all the way down to little
kids these videos just gone viral of
little kids in minneapolis
screaming at cursing at and actually
hitting police officers
you see this little kid
two little black kids
[Music]
yelling profanities at these cops and
swinging it punching the cops
now they're what they're like three
years old or something
walking around in their underwear
and you've got some older people you've
got some adults behind them or at least
older teenagers maybe adults
also shirtless
not wearing all their clothing pants
down below their underwear
allowing this to happen
how do you think life is going to turn
out for those kids
not great
what are the cops going to do
the cop one the cops are not going to
arrest little kids the cops are not even
going to stop little kids from hitting
them and especially they're not going to
stop them because they're black kids and
because this is minneapolis and we're
living in the era post-george floyd
where
ben stein made this point the other day
where you have explicit calls from
people in political authority to let
peop black people commit crimes let
black people off the hook for crimes
punish people of other races
specifically white people to a greater
degree for crimes and have a two-tiered
system
and they justify with all sorts of
piffle about
systemic oppression and history and all
this other stuff
but what they're saying is
go let even during the blm riots they
said we just need to let people vent
their emotions by
by stealing gucci handbags and nike
sneakers we just need to let people let
it out by torching the city but only for
a night or two then we're going to bring
law and order back
do you think that's good
yeah it's good for black people
yeah that's good for anybody i don't
think that's good at all do you think
these little kids who obviously have
complete deadbeat degenerate parents if
they have parents that i'm not even sure
if the parents are around whoever those
older
adults are in the frame though they're
sort of just slightly out of frame you
can only see part of their bodies but
whoever they are they're completely
irresponsible they're they're neglecting
the the education of these kids the kids
are statistically very likely to turn
out bad i mean they don't even put the
kids in clothing the adults themselves
aren't wearing clothing
do you think that's going to set these
kids up for success no
the best thing that could possibly
happen
to these kids is f and there's really no
way politically for it even to occur
right now in minneapolis is for those
cops to grab the little kids and say hey
stop it
naughty naughty naughty don't do that
you're not allowed to hit police
officers shut your mouth don't use that
kind of language i'm going to wash your
mouth out with soap
your parents if they're even around need
to be punished a little more severely
than you i'm just giving you a stern
talking to but stop it you're not going
to have a successful life if you do that
it's wrong for you to do that wrong for
your for you to speak to your elders
that way wrong for you to speak to law
enforcement that way
and if you continue down this path
you're gonna have a terrible life and
you're gonna wind up like hunter biden
so don't do it it's a bad it's a bad
idea that's
that's not
harming a kid that's not oppressing a
kid that's loving a kid
that's
it's tough love but it's what people
need a little bit of tough love
sometimes and the parents could use
really tough love the parents could use
a little bit more than a stern talking
to the parents should be told get your
life together get get your kids in line
or
or else
or or you're going to be wearing the
orange jumpsuit that hunter will not be
wearing speaking of getting tough
the 2024 race is heating up on the
republican side and you are seeing now a
battle
of the two biggest brashest billionaires
on social media
you are seeing a battle between donald
trump and elon musk
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i pull that
one right
leon
i tell you what
elon
elon
is not going to buy twitter
where did you hear that before
from me
[Music]
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me he voted for me
so he's another artist but he's not
going to be buying it
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later who the hell
knows what's going to happen he's got a
pretty rotten contract i looked at his
contract not a good contract
rotten it's absolutely so he's really
going after elon musk here and he's
doing it
in the way that trump always goes after
people
he lets the other guy hit first
this is not an aggressive
this is not a pre-emptive attack on elon
musk elon hit him first in trump's mind
by saying i've never voted for a
republican i've never supported a
republican is that what that means is
elon saying i didn't support trump
so trump says okay
well you told me you did when you came
and groveled for more government
handouts elon so suck it elon you're a
jerk you're not buying twitter it was
all a scam in the first place i told you
i was a scam elon's terrible i'm the man
forget about twitter sign up for truth
social and he just unleashes in that
very trumpy way that wasn't all of it he
then went on truth social
because trump is not allowed on twitter
he went on truth social
posted a picture of elon posing with
president then president trump and says
when elon musk came to the white house
asking me for help on all of his many
subsidized projects whether it's
electric cars that don't drive long
enough driverless cars that crash or
rocket ships to nowhere without which
subsidies he'd be worthless and telling
me how he was a big trump fan and a
republican i could have said drop to
your knees and beg and he would have
done it and then it goes on there's
another there's another one too he just
keeps going on and on and on about elon
musk
because elon did strike first now you
might say
elon has every right to say that he's
not a republican and hasn't voted for
republicans before trump doesn't need to
take this so personally but this is how
trump plays
politics and everybody knows it frankly
i actually don't think that this attack
on elon musk is designed as a message
for elon musk
i think this is a message
for ron desantis
and ted cruz
and mike pompeo and mike pence and nikki
haley and anyone else who might run for
president in 2024.
the message is i'm going to be really
nice we're going to play nice
until you
in even the slightest way come after me
and then i am going to go
nuclear on you
and elon happens to be the the object of
that ire right now but the message is
not for elon the message is for the
people who could challenge trump and
it's a message that desantis and all the
rest of the potential 2024 people should
take very seriously
because right now trump is so far up in
the polls he's got the support of the
republicans even though i know a lot of
very
politically active aware very online
conservatives are saying you know i
liked trump but
he's had his time it's time to move on
that's what elon said you know uh well
maybe maybe we should move i think i
think elon said something to this effect
you know it's time sort of time to move
on
and
i i don't that's not where the
republican base is right now that's not
where the polls the polls are right now
and so
you you're now in this position actually
i think the way elon phrased it was he
said there should also be an age limit
for president you shouldn't be able to
run for president over the age of 69 and
i think it was just so he could make a
joke about the number 69 which is kind
of the way that he plays social media as
well
but this is a game this is a high level
game and
people down in florida
people down in texas people up in all
over the place all over the country who
might be considering a run for president
are taking note of this sort of thing
now
i think there is a chance for some
republican candidates to beat trump 2024
is a long way away other people though
are delusional one of whom is
the governor of maryland larry hogan
who in an interview that was just
published yesterday
told cbs news that more and more people
are encouraging him to run for president
who are these people are any of those
people out there are we where is the
nationwide wave of hogan mentum coming
around where is i don't i don't quite
see it in the polls
one of the ironies for the people who
are most critical of trump is that they
themselves
uh
embody all of the ticks and even the
worst eccentricities that they accuse
trump of having
you know so you you'd have the lincoln
project remember the lincoln project
with the that
speaking of pedophiles and sex crimes uh
the lincoln project was this group of
repub republican consultants who got
pushed out of the game because trump
didn't want to hire them and so
because they're absolute prostitutes
they just went and worked for the
democrats and raised a lot of money from
democrats
and then said we we're principled
republicans we're not like that
unprincipled boar vulgarian donald trump
we're principled and then they ran the
most vulgar boorish disgusting campaigns
you could imagine we're not like this
terrible man donald trump who has no
character meanwhile the lincoln project
gets caught as being a bunch of
pederasts homosexual pedos who were
trying to groom young kids and
offer them the prospect of jobs if they
would uh if they would engage in sex
acts with them well while these guys
cheated on their wives so
they whatever they could accuse trump of
on the sex front on the rhetoric front
on any front they themselves were
embodying much worse behavior and you're
even seeing hints of that here with
larry hogan
he says listen
more and more people are telling me to
run look look everybody's talking about
it they're all saying larry hogan we
really want larry to run for president
it's like a really sad caricature of a
guy trying to do a donald trump
impression and obviously nobody wants
this guy to run for president
probably most of his own family doesn't
want him to run for president
hogan's argument is there's a
diminishing number of folks that are
wanting the former president trump to
run there's a growing number of people
that are looking for our kind of
successful bigger tent politics
even this even this line
successful bigger tent politics donald
trump is the biggest tent republican
that the most successfully big tent
republican i've ever seen in my lifetime
donald trump expanded
the republican party's reach to hispanic
voters
donald trump expanded the republican
party's reach to black voters donald
trump expanded the republican party's
reach to working-class voters who were
previously
democrats union democrats blue-collar
workers he greatly expanded the
republican party's reach to that
demographic donald trump expanded the
republican party's reach to gay voters
for goodness sakes
donald trump he was he was the first
presidential candidate to ever launch
his campaign supporting gay marriage
joe biden didn't start his political
campaigns supporting gay marriage
certainly not barack obama or hillary
clinton all of whom said that marriage
is a sacred union between a man and a
woman now you might say well i wish
donald trump did defend
the
traditional understanding of marriage
that prevailed everywhere for all of
human history until five minutes ago
maybe you say i wish that were the case
but one thing you can accuse him of is
not being big tent the guy's a very very
big tent
is larry hogan a big tent republican
what's his base of support
does 66 of the republican party want
larry hogan to be president i don't
think so
speaking of governors that i don't like
very much
democrat up in new york kathy hokel
who is trying to take away new yorkers
second amendment rights this clip came
from a week or two ago but i really want
to get to it
because it shows you the kind of hubris
that you're seeing
from the ruling class so yet a major win
for the second amendment in new york
thanks to the u.s supreme court the
supreme court in the new york pistol and
rifle association case
came out and said that new yorkers have
a right to keep and bear arms and they
can carry weapons and that's that so new
york is really upset some of their gun
laws were struck down they're trying to
institute new gun laws and a reporter
asked this governor hokel a question
said hold on is there do you have any
evidence that the guns that you're
banning and the people you're banning
from owning guns are actually involved
in the homicide problem in new york
here's hokel's answer
do you have the numbers to show that
it's the concealed carry permit holders
that are committing crimes because the
lawful gun owner will say that you're
attacking the wrong person it's really
people that are getting these guns
illegally that are causing the violence
not the people going and getting the
permit legally and that's the basis for
the whole supreme court argument
do you have the numbers
i don't need to have numbers
i don't need i don't have to have a data
point to point to to say that this is
going to matter all i know is i have a
responsibility to the people of this
state to have sensible gun safety laws
and this one was not devised by the
local administration it comes out of an
administration from 1908 and i don't
need a data point to make the case that
i have a responsibility to protect the
people of this state
sure that's true you don't need you
don't need statistics
to know that you have a responsibility
to protect the people of the state but
the question is do you have any evidence
that your law will protect the people of
the state
hochel is using a clever rhetorical
device here because i also think that
statistics are generally bogus and
statistics come about in the last really
only in the last
150 200 years or so and it comes as part
of this big expansion of the
technocratic state
the very word statistic refers to the
the data that go into the management of
the state and it it has all sorts of
problems for conservative political
philosophy and it really feeds into the
progressive project broadly so i i'm
also
not that interested in citing statistic
after statistic
but you do need evidence don't you
yes it's true your job kathy hokel is to
pursue justice your job is to protect
the people of your state and ensure the
common good okay
what is your evidence
that these gun laws will do it she said
i don't have any evidence
i don't have a statistic
i don't even have an anecdote i have no
i don't have a philosophical argument i
don't have any evidence whatsoever i
just want to do it
i'm just going to do it and that is a
kind of governance without
logic
that is
we got we got two faculties we can use
when we're talking about government here
when we're talking about our even our
own personal lives we've got our will
and we've got our intellect
intellect without will you're not gonna
do very much will without intellect
you're not gonna do very many good
things ideally you combine the two and
you allow your intellect to inform your
will and then you act in a way that is
in accordance with right reason and with
the good
that's when politics is functioning best
and the founding fathers wrote about
these sorts of things at great length
that's kind of what this government was
supposed to be about
when you divorce the will from the
intellect then you get
tyranny essentially then you just get
people a politics that that devolves to
people just pursuing their own
basest immediate unreasonable
interests
and and desires and that is not very
good government at all there you can't
have civil dialogue there you can't have
reasonable debate
there it's just two teams clubbing each
other into one side wins and
unfortunately it's not it's not the
troglodytes with the big thick
eyebrows who are you know look like
neanderthals dragging clubs around who
are pursuing this kind of politics it's
all the geniuses who went to all the
really good schools who wear the really
fancy lab coats who tell you get your
17th booster shot because this one's
going to be very safe and effective and
that's going to do whatever we say even
when what we say contradicts what we
said just yesterday even when there's no
logic to it whatsoever you will do what
i do what i tell you to do you will
comply or else that's the kind of
politics we're looking at it's why we
gotta get really really tough here if we
want to
return in any way to a politics informed
by reason i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire